all right as many of you know
um one of the races that i find to
really point to
just the absurdity of the united states
of america is the georgia senate race in
which incumbent democratic senator
rafael warnock is being challenged by a
man who has already won the republican
primary race his name is herschel walker
he used to be a football player and one
of the reasons that i find this race so
disturbing
is that herschel walker quite literally
cannot speak herschel water walker is
incoherent herschel walker cannot
explain his views on any political issue
herschel walker will not debate raphael
warnock but is starting to claim that
warnock is actually the one who won't
debate him
it is
extraordinarily disturbing because you
have a man who quite literally cannot
speak it's impossible to know what he
thinks about anything
and he's only down like a point
to the incumbent democratic senator
rafael warnock
take a look at some of these new clips
that i have
from herschel walker
at a rally i guess it's called a rally
although it's not clear whether i mean
this could be a eulogy or a rally you
can't tell it's it's not clear whether
this is a happy event or a sad event or
what because it's not clear what he's
talking about here is herschel walker
talking about a bull in a field with six
cows
tell me if you can understand what he's
talking about here tell you this little
story i heard one time
it's about everybody thinking something
is better somewhere else
and i remember talking about this boy
that was out in the field
and he had six cows with him
three of them were suspecting calves
he had these six cows but what he was
worried about he kept his nose up
against the fence seeing these other
three cows up on the hillside
oh is this like a grass's greener
parable so as he's looking up on the
hillside of these other three cows not
worried about what he got now the grass
is as tall as his knees all he had to do
is he grabs
but he's worried about something else
and so one day he measured that fence up
he measured that fence up and he said
you know i think i can jump this fence
and get over there and those other cows
now don't worry about what he got i can
jump it i'm getting over there
so as he got back went out the news he
took off running and he dove
and as he made it over the fence his
better got all cut up and stuff he
rolled up and he got up and he knew he
would have made it on the other side he
was so excited about it
and then he ran to the top of the hill
when he got up there he realized that
they were bulls too
and the reason i tell you that
don't think something is better
somewhere else okay i mean i guess he's
saying in a very strange way
don't fall for the grass is greener on
the other side and i okay fine um here's
another story
of a guy who got to the pearly gates
and it was a trick of some kind and this
is about this story of this
man that died and he went to heaven
early
and when he got to heaven saint peter
met him at the pearly gates
and st peter said you're here early
right now
and your name ain't on the road
but he said i'm going to give you an
opportunity
to decide where you want to go
he said you can go to heaven or you can
go to hell and i'll give you a chance to
decide for yourself
and he puts him in his elevator and he
takes him all the way down to hell
and the doors open up
and there's a party going on
there's a lot of his friends down there
and they're having a good time
and so after a couple of hours ago saint
peter came to him and said uh we got to
leave now we got to leave he said we got
to go he's in here you got to go right
now
so he puts him in this elevator he takes
him all the way up to heaven and they
get to heaven and the doors open up
and there's people floating around on
clouds
they're having a good time
and after a couple of hours saint peter
came to him and said are you ready to
make the decision
and the guy said well saint pete
i need to tell you this
but i think i want to go to hell
he said are you sure he's a yeah
really has a way with
words it seems like my type of place
so he puts him in his elevator
they go all the way down the hell now
when the doors open up now it's hot
hotter than today it's hot
people are looking miserable that
terrible they're just crying okay i'm
not gonna subject you to the uh to the
rest of it folks uh this guy's polling
46 percent in georgia i'm sorry 45 in
georgia um right now if you look at
polling georgia senate herschel walker
versus raphael warnock
walker is only behind by on average one
point in fact the latest poll from
emerson
has walker ahead by two
now
maybe you don't agree with everything
raphael warnock stands for
maybe you don't like all of his policy
positions
but we send 100 people to the u.s senate
and some intellectual capacity and
cognitive ability
should be a requirement and this is not
about you know i know every time we talk
about this david well you're making fun
of people who have mental illness does
walker have mental illness and i'm not
making fun of that you're making fun of
people who have
a brain injury
does walker have a brain injury i'm not
making fun of that or what
this is a position
that has certain intellectual
requirements or at least it should so
it's even if those things were true
about herschel walker
it would still not be a reason to make
him a united states senator
here's one bonus here's walker i guess
outlining his educational plan in our
school you seen it all kids are behind
because they want to be woke
they want to be warm
what about teaching them how to write
what about teaching them how to read
what about teaching them how to spell
yeah but right now we've elected people
to watch that want to profit off the
bikes or the misery they're giving to us
yeah
um woke profits are the reason
i guess school is bad at this point in
time so
i know people have been emailing me
emailing me and saying david you know
i've seen a lot of morons be elected to
public office you know i was around for
the bush era and then trump
but
there's something about if walker wins
that they will be completely despondent
and i have to tell you that i get it i
really do
so i was briefly on a reality show
called the dish and this is really
pretty funny um this is a show where
mama june shannon
is on the treasure coast of florida
she's trying to help my friend tv star
adam barta
seize the opportunity of a lifetime
there are frenemies there's drama
there's all sorts of stuff going on for
our howard stern fans
tan mom is a part of it it's just
completely crazy and i appear on the
show and the dish is our sponsor today
and it's all just delightfully
ridiculous and i would love for you to
check out the show it's only 299 for a
24 minute episode and you can watch it
on apple tv
you simply go to david davidpakman.com
dish
let me know once you've seen it what you
think about my
reality show debut i'm curious to hear
from you that's davidpakman.com
dish